o no
[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este espacio de
radio francia internacional y france 24
hoy dedicamos el programa a la música
con un proyecto muy especial que asocia
música con ciencia el proyecto es de
eduardo makaroff y christoph müller de
gotan proyect que hoy hacen escala en
parís para presentarnos en exclusiva su
último trabajo antropoceno muchísimas
gracias a los dos por estar con nosotros
bueno eduardo makaroff argentino cristo
miller suizo llevan trabajando juntos
desde los años 90 en 1998 crearon gotan
proyect en parís junto al dj francés
philippe cohen solal en 2001 revoluciona
en el mundo del tango y de la
electrónica con su primer álbum la
revancha del tango que tuvo un éxito
planetario y desde entonces han
continuado trabajando juntos con
trabajos como por ejemplo plaza francia
con la cantante francesa que accionan se
de la mítica banda rita mitsuko el
proyecto que presentan ahora es un tanto
diferente
sea él el más comprometido en este caso
contra el cambio climático lleva por
nombre antropoceno que sería ahora nos
lo explicarán mejor una era geológica
posterior al holoceno a la que habríamos
entrado ya según una parte de la
comunidad científica porque la accionar
de las personas está modificando el
planeta este es un proyecto en defensa
de la tierra eduardo y bueno sí sería
muy pretencioso
digamos que sí que es un proyecto un
poco militante y que es nuestro granito
de arena con respecto a lo que está
pasando en lo que bien puede escribirte
el antropoceno
que les impulsó a ir en esta dirección
christophe que
cuando dijeron bueno tenemos que hacer
algo que vaya en ese camino bueno ahora
nos parece un poquito evidente nosotros
hablamos mucho por ejemplo en giras
hablamos mucho de lo que pasa en el
mundo también somos apasionados de
ciencia todos y así bueno
pienso que tal vez sea un poquito más
eduardo que lee mucho mucho sobre
antropología y y me inicio un poquito
también más aunque yo soy historiador de
formación pero más historia
contemporánea así pero me fascina
y estoy seguro seguro estamos trabajando
en unos temas
y salió esta idea de ahora ahora ahora
que ahora en general con nosotros las
ideas vienen de la música es la música
que nos no sé que nos transporte por por
los caminos más que quiera como ahora
hacemos eso y explicarnos un poquito
porque no es un álbum y aún por el
momento es un proyecto con varios temas
y hay otros que están haciéndose no
exactamente no pero para digamos para
completar lo que dijo en nosotros cuando
nos ponemos a componer lo hacemos de una
manera más que nada intuitiva y digamos
con una cierta espontaneidad entonces
recién cuando venimos aquí a comentarte
que estamos haciendo esto digamos
iniciando nos a nosotros mismos y
poniendo las ideas en orden y
efectivamente el digamos el choque con
este momento de la historia de la
humanidad y de la tierra
nos inspiró naturalmente con una
evidencia es una evidencia
estamos viviendo ahora una evidencia de
una pandemia que es parte del
antropoceno sí porque algunos
científicos dicen que hay un vínculo muy
estrecho directo entre por ejemplo la
tala de árboles y los animales salvajes
bueno pues los animales salvajes con los
que están en criadero y de ahí vienen
por ahí vino el virus si les parece
vamos con un extracto de este proyecto
del tema ahora
[Música]
reconocen más
no existes no voy a negar su estado
[Música]
bueno en este tema aparece el famoso
discurso de la activista sueca greta
thunberg creo que es en la cob 24 de
polonia a quien se le ocurrió de los dos
poner el discurso de creta no tenemos
costumbre de dividir los aspectos
creativos individuales y duarte y ni me
acuerdo
es nuestra cocina interno
hemos seguido no me acuerdo que vos lo
que hiciste fue elegida las frases
claves de este famoso discurso y creo
que están muy bien elegidas es una
fuente de inspiración
no entiendo la polémica que hay internet
o grace entonces no realmente no lo
entiendo porque esta chica o esta joven
mujer ahora mismo parece una genia si
logró movilizar a muchos jóvenes para
una unas movilizaciones que se pararon
justamente porque empezó la pandemia
pero cada viernes había movilizaciones
en todo el mundo es una persona que
tiene una sensibilidad muy fuerte y
pienso que lo siente todo esto o lo ve
más claro que incluso nosotros
y cuando nosotros tomamos la conciencia
o yo tomando la consciencia de lo que
está pasando de guerra
una vez que estás como dando cuenta es
muy fuerte es no sé cómo explicarlo bien
es como un punto de basf ilmo un punto
de inflexión hay gente que incluso está
deprimida por la situación planetaria
digamos de cambio climático ahí incluso
hay gente que lo está teorizando los
deprimidos por el tema de una cosa que
hay que señalar es que lo que está
pasando en el planeta no es solo el
cambio climático eso es lo más conocido
un poco menos conocido es la extinción
de la vida sobre el planeta la sexta
extinción masiva de las vidas y el punto
de eso y hemos hecho una canción
pero quería decir que nosotros no
hacemos digamos una música con un pactos
o con una digamos tratamos de
divertirnos cuando hacemos esto bueno se
ve en el vídeo este pero se va a
escuchar también tenemos invitados
invitadas y nos divertimos y tenemos un
sentido optimista pensamos que no
estábamos en la catástrofe y hay que
ponerse a llorar y tampoco hacemos lo
que sería la canción de protesta oigan
miran lo que está pasando que se lo
estamos digamos puse buscando creando
con una cierta espontaneidad canto un
poco el camino porque no es evidente
hablar de esta temática que es un poco
interesada en canciones pero también
como dijo eduardo somos un poco
optimistas también y pensamos que esta
es una oportunidad pero todo el mundo
tiene que ponerse al trabajo
ayer hacia el cambio este proyecto
cuenta con la participación de muchos
artistas con los que están trabajando
creando divirtiéndose desde italia está
el rapero y poeta adoro ya no sé si lo
pronunció bien y desde argentína fermín
a que es un grupo de la patagonia
también hilda lizarazu y me ha molino
cómo fue la selección de estos artistas
hubo un criterio ambiental
yo diría que fue un criterio de
contactos amistades
azar el azar y la lizarazu y su hija mía
felino vinieron a parís y dijimos vengan
graben que estamos grabando unas cosas y
lo hicieron con una escala y parece una
escala en parís e hicieran exactamente
qué más
las chicas féminas las hiciste descubrir
en un momento dado agarra el teléfono
como nos gustó nos gustaron
las llamamos qué es lo que hacemos
generalmente con las colaboraciones
porque hay colaboraciones que como que
se sugieren o sea a veces casi se
imponen por las compañías discográficas
y otras colaboraciones que son digamos
en contactos naturales o el gusto
nuestro y las ganas de trabajar con
alguien que usted parece que tiene tiene
que ver con lo que hacemos y como
dijimos antes la música también
nos lleva y nos lleva exactamente lo que
a lo mejor con el tema también más y
tenemos podemos decir lo que tenemos
otros invitados será que ya dicen están
gravados tenemos a kevin johansen
también y a una cantante folclórica que
se llama mariana carrizo también hay un
francés y que en realidad él sí es un
científico y él sabría explicar
muchísimo mejor todo lo que nosotros
no hacemos también que eso daría embargo
en realidad sacamos parte de su discurso
y es una realidad es un astrofísico de
altísimo nivel un gran profesor pero que
explica muy bien lo que está pasando
justamente en el planeta con la
extinción de la vida hicimos un tema que
se llama la sexta extinción
este working progress me da la impresión
bueno hay tango y hay electrónica pero
es mucho más folclórico no que otros
trabajos que han hecho
si digamos que con gotan proyect y con
plaza francia si nos circunscribimos más
que nada el tango llevará el tango al
encuentro con la música electrónica con
las nuevas tecnologías o el de la
cantante de rock
y esta vez nos fuimos al resto de
latinoamérica
el folklore argentino que ya lo habíamos
incorporado en gotan proyect pero
también digamos que no ampliamos nuestro
nuestro aspecto nuestro límite
geográfico
antes de terminar me gustaría que
habláramos del videoclip de la canción
de la casa mía en la que canta el
italiano duro del chat del que
hablábamos antes
con ventanas de todo el planeta y el que
ha sido realizado por la guatemalteca
daniela pintó con la que están también
trabajando no si seguimos con eso habrá
un nuevo vídeo que es para el próximo
tema con mariana carrizo que se llama el
hierro de la tierra
y ella es una especialista de hacer este
tipo de montajes muy rápidos eso por eso
también la contratamos al principio
porque había hecho un vídeo para un
amigo que se llama chancha vía circuito
un tema donde
utilizo muchas muchas imágenes de una
mano del animal
a una oruga una buenísima y como
nosotros tuvimos esta idea de ventanas
pero muchas ventanas muy rápidamente del
mundo físico del mundo entero es
imposible hicimos un call por internet y
recibimos muchos muchas ventanas del
mundo entero se y ella hizo un trabajo
espectacular bueno pues no nos queda más
tiempo muchísimas gracias eduardo y
christoph por haber venido hasta
nuestros estudios y les deseamos
muchísimo éxito con este proyecto y
progres porque no se ha terminado
antropoceno muchísimas gracias
muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir en internet en rf y
mundo.com y en france24 punto com hasta
pronto
tanto si ves que no vale
no eres diferente
[Música]
gracias a la final tras casa mía el
plato que cambia colores mientras le
falle